let there be no doubt at all that if
putin makes this choice russia will pay
a heavy price a day after leaving his
stance on russian aggression unclear the
u.s president was unequivocal any
any assembled russian units move across
ukrainian border that is an invasion and
that biden says will be met with a
severe and coordinated economic response
from the west
for people in eastern ukraine days of
diplomatic dialogue aren't easing
anxieties
i hope they will reach the point that we
and they need and then we'll return to
peace and harmony says this man but
peace may be out of reach
russian military exercises have
intensified the kremlin showing off a
new submarine expected to conduct drills
next month in the mediterranean
for now ukraine's allies are seeking
solidarity in the face of force the
united states together with our allies
and partners have offered a diplomatic
path out of this contrived crisis but
unity may not be easily achieved french
president emmanuel macron is suggesting
the european union forge its own
so-called stability and security pact
with moscow the prime minister is as we
speak looking at a range of options
canada still won't say what if any
equipment it will contribute to bolster
ukraine's military capabilities on the
eve of a critical summit it seems
canada's role is to rally support we are
that country that bring people to the
table and make sure that we can find a
solution with troops already on the
ground in ukraine as part of operation
unifier some believe canada's current
actions are key trying to
keep everybody else at the table and
keep going on this because the moment
you stop talking
we're into a bad scene avoiding that is
the goal of the meeting in geneva friday
between the american secretary of state
and russia's foreign minister
mike lacouter global news ottawa